[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Oh! Wo sind eigentlich die Lebkuchen?
Nee, jetzt ohne Spaß.
Ich wollte doch diese Nürnberger Lebkuchen zeigen.
>> JOSH: Ja, die hat der Murat gegessen.
>> SALLY: Oh!
Die hat der Murat gegessen.
Ich habe die extra gekauft für den Dreh heute.
Und ich weiß, dass er sie
– o mein Gott! Der hat sie letzte Woche gegessen.
>> JOSH: Hat er sie echt gegessen?
>> SALLY: Ja.
Oh nein!
Egal. Jetzt machen wir es.
Ich gucke noch, ob ich hier noch eine habe.
Vielleicht haben wir eine noch versteckt.
Aber – oh nein!
Da sind nur Spekulatius und Yogurette.
Zeig nicht unser Süßigkeitenversteck da oben!
Sonst
– ach, wobei, der guckt sich das ja nicht an
nach dem Schnitt, oder?
Oder doch?
>> JOSH: Ich weiß nicht.
>> SALLY: O mein Gott!
Die Lebkuchen sind weg!
Okay. Ich fange noch mal an.
Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Ja, heute backe ich...
Murat?
Kann das sein,
dass du die Nürnberger Lebkuchen gegessen hast?
>> MURAT: Ja, habe ich.
>> SALLY: Ich habe die doch für den Dreh gebraucht.
>> MURAT: Also, wenn es was Leckeres gibt,
sind es die Lim-
– Limburger?! –
Nürnberger Lebkuchen.
Ist es dir aufgefallen?
>> SALLY: Ich habe die für den Dreh gebraucht.
>> MURAT: Ja, wieso denn?
>> SALLY: Und eben wollte ich die am Anfang zeigen
und denke so: "O mein Gott!
Ich habe sie nicht mehr im Schrank."
>> MURAT: Ich habe sie mit der Ela zusammen gegessen.
>> SALLY: Och, Schatz!
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Okay, ich kann jetzt eins tun:
Also heute möchte ich...
>> MURAT: Ja, am Kinoabend.
Wir hatten einen Kinoabend mit der Ela.
>> SALLY: Stimmt.
Oh nein!
Ich kann jetzt eins tun:
Also ich backe heute Nürnberger Lebkuchen.
Das sind diese großen,
werden auch Elisenlebkuchen genannt.
Ich habe die auch mal vor zig Jahren zubereitet.
Aber ich habe mir gedacht: "Komm.
Wir machen sie noch einmal."
Und damals habe ich sie als Miniversion gemacht
und heute will ich so richtig große.
Wie sie aussehen, könnt ihr hier der Packung entnehmen.
Leider kann ich sie euch nicht in echt zeigen,
da mein Mann und meine vierjährige Tochter
sie leider schon gegessen haben.
Okay. Ich kann ihnen halt auch nicht böse sein.
Die sind einfach zu süß.
Ich hätte sie euch gern gezeigt.
Aber ist egal.
Jeder weiß doch, wie Lebkuchen aussehen, oder, Josh?
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Also hier haben wir die Zutaten.
Was bei Nürnberger Lebkuchen tatsächlich wichtig ist,
dass wirklich kein Mehl benutzt wird
oder maximal
– ich glaube, 10% ist so die Grenze.
Denn die Lebkuchen bestehen aus Nüssen, aus Mandeln,
aus ein bisschen Orangeat, Zitronat.
Und das ist natürlich eine richtig geniale Kombination.
Und das macht die Lebkuchen so supersaftig,
aromatisch und lecker.
Ich verwende dafür
sechs Eier,
180 Gramm braunen Zucker,
40 Gramm Honig.
Hier habe ich die Lebkuchengewürze,
nämlich Zimt,
Muskatnuss
und eine Prise Salz,
etwas Kardamom,
gemahlene Nelken
und Vanilleextrakt,
jeweils 250 Gramm Mandeln
und Haselnüsse,
jeweils 200 Gramm Zitronat
und Orangeat.
Ich nehme hier noch eine frische Ingwerwurzel
und Backoblaten.
Und wie gesagt, mache ich jetzt große Lebkuchen.
Und deswegen habe ich jetzt diesmal
die Oblaten mit 90 cm Durchmesser.
Denn ich finde, so große Lebkuchen sind schon schön, gell?
Was habe ich gesagt?
>> JOSH: 90 cm.
>> SALLY: Mit 90
– oh, so einen Riesen!
So ein Riesenlebkuchen, das wäre schon auch mal...
Aber okay, wir machen heute 9,
9 cm.
Ich bin völlig durcheinander.
Ach herrje!
Okay. Was ich jetzt zuerst machen werde,
das empfehle ich euch auch immer:
Wenn ihr Nüsse und Mandeln benutzt,
dann mahlt sie einfach selber.
Denn so haben sie wirklich das volle Aroma noch hier drinnen
und sind einfach leckerer als jetzt gekaufte gemahlene Nüsse.
Das muss man halt echt ganz ehrlich sagen.
So. Das mache ich jetzt da oben
mit einem Mixmesser.
Super!
Ich meine, ich habe es jetzt schon abgewogen,
aber ich könnte es theoretisch auch hier abwiegen.
Guckt mal. Dann gehe ich nämlich hier direkt auf "Zero".
Mein Papa!
Da ist er.
Wenn er jetzt hier drin wäre, würde er sagen:
"Türkiye'ye selamlar!" – "Grüße in die Türkei!"
Ich muss sagen, wenn ich jetzt nicht für euch,
für die Kamera backen würde,
hätte ich mir das jetzt vorher auch nicht abgewogen,
sondern einfach direkt hier drinnen.
Da kann man sich nämlich ganz viele Schälchen sparen.
So. Jetzt einfach kurz zerkleinern.
[Musik]
Die Nüsse und Mandeln habe ich jetzt rausgenommen.
Jetzt noch Orangeat und Zitronat.
Und da muss ich echt dazusagen:
Das schmeckt man später nicht raus.
Also man schmeckt schon dieses Fruchtige.
Was ich aber persönlich auch nicht mag, ist,
wenn man auf Orangeat und Zitronat beißt.
Das finde ich einfach furchtbar eklig.
Aber, wenn ihr es zerkleinert
und sich das dann mit den Nüssen
und mit den Mandeln vermischt,
dann ist es echt perfekt.
Vertraut mir.
Ich gebe jetzt hier noch ein paar Nüsse mit rein,
damit sich das noch ein bisschen besser zerkleinern lässt.
[Musik]
Jetzt gebe ich die Eier in die große Schüssel.
Dann den braunen Zucker dazu.
Der schmeckt einfach aromatischer
als normaler weißer Zucker.
Deswegen nehme ich den jetzt echt ganz gerne.
Dann den Honig dazu.
Ich finde, es würde auch Zuckerrübensirup passen.
Hm.
Also, wenn ihr keinen Honig habt,
dann Zuckerrübensirup.
So.
Und das jetzt erst mal schaumig verrühren,
damit sich der Zucker einfach so ein bisschen auflösen kann.
Ihr könnt auch die Masse leicht erwärmen,
so auf 25°C.
Das könnt ihr auch gerne machen.
Dann löst sich der Zucker auch ein bisschen besser,
muss ich sagen.
[Musik]
Perfekt!
Und jetzt kommen einfach nur noch alle Zutaten rein.
Da kann man jetzt auch echt nichts mehr falsch machen.
Also am Anfang das Schaumigschlagen
bewirkt wirklich auch nur,
dass sich der Zucker einfach schön löst
und sich mit den Eiern gut verbindet.
Ich wechsle nur einmal hier
von Schneebesen auf so einen Flachrührer.
Gut.
Jetzt natürlich noch die ganzen Gewürze dazu.
Zum einen ist ja auch Vanille ein super Gewürz.
Dann hier die trockenen Gewürze.
Und die Muskatnuss, die reibe ich...
Die reibe ich noch so mit rein.
Und den Ingwer reibe ich auch noch rein,
also jetzt nicht das ganze Stück.
Ihr könnt auch getrockneten Ingwer benutzen.
Aber ich nehme jetzt hier den frischen, weil ich den dahabe.
Ich sehe jetzt nur hier gerade
– also Ingwer schäle ich sowieso eigentlich nie.
Und wenn ich hier diese harten Stellen habe,
die entferne ich einfach mit einem Löffel,
also nicht mit einem Messer.
Denn mit dem Messer ist es echt so,
dass man immer zu viel wegnimmt.
Und das muss man nicht.
Einfach so diese harten Augen hier wegnehmen.
[Musik]
Und dann dazu reiben.
So viel, wie ihr möchtet.
Okay, die ist ein bisschen...
Ah, doch, es geht.
[Musik]
Und jetzt
alles nur noch kurz vermischen.
Ich nehme einen Deckel.
Ich habe aus meinen Fehlern gelernt
und ich nehme einen Deckel.
So sollte die Masse dann aussehen,
also eine relativ feste Masse.
Ich habe übrigens auch gerade den Fehler gemacht.
Ich hatte...
Die Masse war einfach zu flüssig.
Und dann fiel mir auf,
dass es wahrscheinlich zu große Eier waren.
Und es waren tatsächlich L-Eier.
Ich habe dann einfach noch mal
die übrigen Zutaten dazu gegeben.
Also bei allen Rezepten solltet ihr immer darauf achten,
dass ich in meinen Mengenangaben
immer M-Eier benutze.
Also, wenn euch mal aufgefallen ist,
dass bei euch auch was vielleicht zu flüssig oder zu fest war,
achtet auf die Eiergröße.
Weil das ist so die Standardgröße.
Und falls ihr größere habt, müsst ihr es einfach umrechnen.
So. Jetzt backe ich hier mit Backoblaten,
wie gesagt, 90 mm Durchmesser.
Und ich nehme jetzt einen Eisportionierer, den großen.
Ich mache das jetzt mal damit.
Ich gucke mal, ob die Masse ausreicht,
aber ich denke, schon.
Ja.
Ich portioniere erst mal ein paar
und dann streiche ich das noch ein bisschen glatt.
Aber, wie gesagt, ihr könnt auch kleinere machen.
Aber ich will schon so nachgemacht,
so "Original trifft Sally",
die großen Lebkuchen.
[Musik]
Und dann nehmt ihr euch ein Schälchen mit Wasser,
befeuchtet die Finger so ein bisschen
und könnt dann die Lebkuchenmasse schön glatt streichen,
so ein bisschen formen.
Da gibt es auch so eine Lebkuchenglocke.
Ich habe sie sogar.
Aber da denke ich mir dann so: "Nee, komm.
Also man macht einmal im Jahr vielleicht Lebkuchen.
Das kann man so formen."
Ein bisschen Rand lassen.
Denn das dehnt sich beim Backen noch ein bisschen.
Aber so, finde ich, ist es eine schöne Größe.
[Musik]
Und guckt mal, wie schön gleichmäßig die sind.
Das kommt einfach durch den Eisportionierer.
Ich meine, ihr könnt auch zwei Esslöffel nehmen.
Aber da habt ihr halt nicht immer die exakt gleiche Größe.
Und so hat man es wirklich schön einfach portioniert.
[Musik]
Und jetzt kommen sie schon in den Backofen.
Den habe ich bereits vorgeheizt auf 150°C Ober-/Unterhitze.
Und die brauchen so circa 20 Minuten.
Und in der Zeit mache ich schon mal die anderen Bleche.
[Musik]
Jetzt haben wir ja die Lebkuchen im Backofen.
Und ich habe mir jetzt gedacht:
"Komm, wir machen noch eine vegane Version."
Denn irgendwie ist das schon so Tradition geworden,
dass ich meine Rezepte, die ich eben mache,
auch in veganer Version zubereite.
Und im Prinzip
sind die Zutaten alle gleich bis auf die Eier.
Und die Eier ersetze ich durch Aquafaba.
Das ist einfach Kichererbsenwasser.
Ich habe jetzt hier die Kichererbsen in der Dose
und das ist ja normalerweise
so der Abfall, den man wegschüttet.
Aber der ist wirklich total proteinreich
und ersetzt einfach ein Eiweiß.
Und das nehme ich jetzt hier.
Und alles andere nehmen wir ganz Standard.
Also, guck mal, jetzt können wir alles hier reinwiegen.
Samira hilft mir jetzt.
Traust du dir denn zu, die Lebkuchen selber fertig zu machen?
>> SAMIRA: Oh ja!
Also dieses...
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> SAMIRA: Die Deko?
>> SALLY: Ja, also so das Draufmachen.
>> SAMIRA: Oh ja.
>> SALLY: Ich zeige es dir gleich
und dann darf es die Samira fertig machen.
[Musik]
Und jetzt nehme ich einfach das Kichererbsenwasser
als Eiersatz und nehme jetzt
– ich mache jetzt sowieso nur die Hälfte
von der gesamten Menge.
Also brauche ich jetzt einfach 150 Gramm.
Und aus den Kichererbsen machen wir uns Hummus
oder noch was Leckeres, gell?
>> SAMIRA: Ja. Oder den Hummus mit der Roten Bete.
>> SALLY: Ja, der war lecker!
>> SAMIRA: Hm.
Hört sich witzig an.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> SAMIRA: Als ob man auf dem Klo wäre.
>> SALLY: Ein bisschen, gell?
Kannst du mal kurz gucken, wie viel...
>> JOSH: Pass auf!
>> SALLY: Oh!
Huch!
>> SAMIRA: Upsala!
Nichts passiert.
>> SALLY: Ich wollte gerade sagen: "Kannst du gucken,
wie viel Zuckerrübensirup?",
aber ich nehme jetzt 20 g.
Denn Honig muss ich natürlich auch ersetzen.
>> SAMIRA: Warte.
>> SALLY: So. Jetzt habe ich
– o mein Gott! –
voll die Sauerei gemacht.
Das mache ich gleich weg.
Kannst du mir Stopp sagen, wenn du da die Zahl siehst?
Und zwar brauche ich 90 Gramm.
>> SAMIRA: Wo ist das, die Zahl?
>> SALLY: Da vorne am Display beim Josh.
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
Nein, warte.
44.
65 – 66.
67.
91.
>> SALLY: Gut.
Passt es?
>> SAMIRA: 91 Gramm. Ja.
>> SALLY: Gut.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: So krass! Es sieht einfach aus
wie eine Eier-Zucker-Masse.
Also gerade jetzt auch mit dem Zuckerrübensirup die Farbe,
exakt gleich.
Und das machen wir jetzt kurz fertig genau wie die anderen.
Und nach dem Backen zeige ich euch direkt,
wie wir die Lebkuchen weiter verarbeiten.
Ich meine, man kann sie ja naturell lassen
– auch gerade bei denen in der Packung ist es ja auch so:
Es gibt die naturell, es gibt Schoko
und es gibt die mit Zucker.
Und bei uns bleiben immer die naturell übrig.
Deswegen werden wir
sie mit Schokolade und mit Zuckerglasur machen.
Samira, vielleicht kannst du die hier gleich formen.
Und ich mache dann schon mal die Schokolade bereit, ja?
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
Du kannst ein bisschen mehr Schokolade machen.
>> SALLY: Guck mal, Samira.
Dann so einen Eisportionierer voll,
abstreifen,
dann hier drauf.
>> SAMIRA: Und dann?
>> SALLY: Und dann nimmst du
– also erst mal würde ich alle portionieren.
Und dann mit den Fingern so ein bisschen
– also mit feuchten Fingern so.
>> SAMIRA: Ah!
Und dann beim Backen zerlaufen die auch noch ein bisschen.
>> SALLY: Genau. Also außenrum einen Rand lassen, ja?
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
>> SALLY: So. Und dann hier drauf.
Und es passen so neun Stück.
>> SAMIRA: Ungefähr so einen Fingernagel groß.
>> SALLY: Genau.
Guck. So.
>> SAMIRA: So?
>> SALLY: Es kann jetzt nur sein,
dass sie eine andere Backzeit haben, aber dann...
Guck mal. Und zwar
– nee, nicht so flach drücken nur, sondern...
>> SAMIRA: Ah! Am Rand,
dass die so ein bisschen einen Hubbel haben.
>> SALLY: Sodass die in der Mitte einen Hubbel haben,
so einen Bauch,
und am Rand leicht runtergehen, nicht?
>> SAMIRA: Wer hat einen Bauch?
>> SALLY: Niemand.
Das schaffst du, oder?
[Musik]
>> SAMIRA: Wie du aussiehst!
>> JOSH: Wa-wa-wa.
>> SAMIRA: Warte mal.
Wa-wa, wa-wa, wa-wa.
[Musik]
So. Fertig.
>> SALLY: Die ersten Lebkuchen sind jetzt schon mal fertig.
Die hier sind komplett abgekühlt.
Die mache ich gleich mit Schokolade.
Die warmen hier werde ich jetzt aber schon mal
mit einer Puderzuckerglasur bestreichen.
Dafür nehme ich jetzt hier Puderzucker.
Und dann nehmt ihr entweder Wasser oder Zitronensaft.
Und ich mag es halt ganz gerne,
wenn so eine leichte Säure dabei ist.
Wer aber wie bei den Originalen
eher einfach nur Puderzucker will, nimmt echt Wasser.
Vanille könnt ihr noch dazu geben,
so ein bisschen vanillig.
Jetzt nicht zu dick,
nicht zu dünn,
also nicht zu viel und nicht zu wenig Zitronensaft.
[Musik]
Ach, wir machen einen Vanille-Zitronen-Guss, oder?
Vanille-Zitrone.
So ist es gut.
Schön dickflüssig.
Und jetzt hier noch warm bestreichen.
Dann zieht das Ganze ein bisschen besser ein.
Und auch jetzt keine zu dicke Schicht auftragen.
Ich finde, das darf jetzt echt nicht zu viel sein.
Ihr müsst übrigens
– je nach Backofen
kann es sein, dass ihr ein paar Minuten
mehr oder weniger backt.
Also achtet einfach darauf,
dass sie diese Farbe ungefähr haben,
so ein schönes Hellbraun.
Ich habe die jetzt nämlich auch noch mal nachgestellt,
aber hole sie jetzt raus.
Und dann auch direkt nach dem Backen immer runternehmen,
damit einfach die Unterseite eben
nicht schwitzt.
Das ist auch wichtig,
damit die Oblaten schön knackig bleiben.
Ich habe jetzt auch die anderen, muss ich sagen,
ganz ohne Folie gemacht,
weil ich ja auch gesehen habe, dass da jetzt nichts ausläuft.
Oh, mit so einem Zimtguss!
Hu!
Ich glaube, die veganen mache ich mit einem Zimtguss.
Oh yes!
>> JOSH: Oder einem Nougatüberzug.
>> SALLY: Uh!
Nougat!
Der wird halt nicht so fest, nicht?
>> JOSH: Dann muss man es halt gleich essen.
>> SALLY: Dann muss man es gleich essen.
Oder du klatschst einfach Nougat zwischen zwei Stück.
>> JOSH: Genau.
>> SALLY: Und dann machst du dir
so einen Lebkuchen-Nougat-Burger.
[Musik]
Und jetzt werde ich die anderen, die bereits abgekühlt sind,
mit Schokolade überziehen.
Ich habe jetzt hier Zartbitterkuvertüre.
Und auch hier einfach darauf achten,
die Kuvertüre zu temperieren.
Das heißt, zwei Drittel davon erwärmen
– nicht zu heiß.
Ich mache es immer so, dass ich das Wasser kochen lasse,
dann den Herd ausmache
und dann mit so einem Schmelzschälchen drauf gehe.
Und dann wird es auch gar nicht heißer also so 50°C ungefähr.
Jetzt kommen hier noch etwas Kokosöl dazu
und die restliche Schokolade.
Also das Drittel
kann jetzt eingerührt werden.
Und dann kühlt die Kuvertüre noch mal schön runter.
[Musik]
Okay. Ich würde jetzt sagen,
wir nehmen mal heute den Dennis dazu zum Verkosten.
Dennis, bitte komme zu uns!
Dr-dr-dr-dr, dl-dl-dl-dl-dlm!
>> JOSH: Hey!
>> DENNIS: Kannst du das bitte verpixeln,
dass man das nicht lesen kann?
Das wäre ganz nett.
[Grillenzirpen]
>> SAMIRA: Das ist doch eh schon verpixelt.
>> DENNIS: Das sollst du doch nicht verraten.
[Tusch]
Sehr schön.
>> SALLY: Also wir haben Lebkuchen gemacht
und, weil ich ja immer an euch auch denke
und an meine veganen Zuschauer, auch in veganer Version.
>> DENNIS: Sehr gut!
>> SALLY: Ja. Deswegen probieren wir mal.
Also so Nürnberger Lebkuchen
– ich wollte eigentlich so das Original dazuhalten.
Ich habe praktisch "Original trifft Sally" wieder nachgemacht.
Aber leider haben die zwei Weihnachtskobolde Murat und Ela
alles schon aufgegessen.
>> DENNIS: Die Weihnachtskobolde?
>> SALLY: Aber komm, die sehen doch schon aus
– oder? – wie die gekauften.
>> DENNIS: Ja.
>> SALLY: Oder?
>> DENNIS: Doch. >> SAMIRA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> SAMIRA: Welche sind überhaupt gekauft?
>> SALLY: Ja, deswegen. Ich habe keine gekauften mehr da.
>> DENNIS: Die sind schon weg.
Die sind schon gegessen.
>> SAMIRA: Ah, ja!
>> SALLY: Ich habe auch noch welche ohne Glasur,
muss ich auch sagen.
Weil die sind noch nicht ganz fertig, ein Blech.
>> DENNIS: Darf ich schon probieren?
>> SALLY: Ja, ihr dürft probieren.
>> SAMIRA: Nein, stopp! Zu dritt.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> SAMIRA: Eins,
>> SALLY: Ich probiere einmal ohne Glasur.
>> SAMIRA: zwei,
>> SALLY & SAMIRA: drei.
>> SAMIRA: Oha, voll lecker!
>> DENNIS: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Lebkuchen.
>> DENNIS: Hm.
>> SALLY: Mmh! Hm.
>> DENNIS: Ich bin Team Weiß auch.
>> SALLY: Ja?
>> DENNIS: Ich mag lieber Lebkuchen mit weißer Glasur.
>> SALLY: Mmh!
>> DENNIS: Mmh!
>> SAMIRA: Zuckerglasur.
>> DENNIS: Sorry.
>> SALLY: Ich muss sagen:
Meine Lebkuchen schmecken mir auch ohne Glasur.
Aber ich probiere trotzdem.
Mein Liebling ist ja Zartbitter.
>> SAMIRA: Hm.
>> SALLY: Und ich mache noch den Vergleich.
Ich meine, du probierst jetzt die veganen.
Schmeckt es vegan?
Schmeckt es pflanzlich?
>> DENNIS: Ganz normal.
>> SALLY: Nee, nicht?
>> DENNIS: Wie Lebkuchen.
>> SALLY: Aber ich muss auch sagen, ich habe jetzt auch
– das war jetzt auch ein veganer ohne Glasur noch.
Und man sieht es auch optisch null!
>> DENNIS: Aber beim...
Ich sage mal, so generell beim Lebkuchen ist ja
die Mischung, also quasi die Gewürze, die da drin sind,
die machen den Geschmack ja.
>> SAMIRA: Ist das auch vegan?
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> SAMIRA: Oha!
>> DENNIS: Und die Konsistenz ist wie...
>> SAMIRA: Darf ich ein bisschen probieren?
>> DENNIS: Ja, mach. Schmeckt lecker.
>> SALLY: Schmeckt...
>> DENNIS: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Hm.
Schmeckt exakt gleich.
Man muss ja auch sagen:
Der Hauptbestandteil von eben diesem Elisenlebkuchen
sind ja die Nüsse
und die kandierten Früchte
und das Ei bindet ja im Prinzip nur.
Und bei der veganen Version hatte ich ja einfach
– statt Eiweiß und statt Ei
hatte ich dieses Kichererbsenwasser,
was ja auch genau wie Ei schmeckt.
>> DENNIS: Hm.
>> SALLY: Und von daher
– und es sah genauso aus sogar.
>> SAMIRA: Mama?
>> SALLY: Hm? Schmeckt gleich, gell?
>> SAMIRA: Das und das ist einfach das Gleiche.
>> SALLY: Eben.
Dennis, möchtest du
unserer Community noch etwas sagen?
>> DENNIS: Mh.
Ich bin gerade am Überlegen.
Was könnte ich denn sagen?
Ja, stimmt!
Hört euch unseren Podcast an!
Der ist superspannend!
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> DENNIS: Wo gibt es den?
>> SALLY: Überall, auf allen Podcast-Streaming-Diensten.
>> DENNIS: Podcast! Also...
>> SALLY: Kostenlos.
>> DENNIS: Kostenlos und unverbindlich
reinhören, reinschnuppern.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> DENNIS: Von der ersten Folge an hört alles durch.
Es wird noch spannender.
>> SALLY: Suchtgefahr! Man bleibt halt dran hängen.
Wir erzählen nämlich so unsere Geschichte, wie alles begann.
Manchmal ein bisschen aktuelle Themen,
manchmal alte Themen
und manchmal fallen uns einfach Sachen ein,
die ich sogar selbst schon längst vergessen habe.
Also eigentlich ist es wie Ehetherapie,
nur kostet sie für uns nichts.
Ist echt gut!
Wir reden echt gut miteinander, Murat
– also nicht Dennis und ich, sondern Murat und ich.
Es hört sich jetzt so an, nicht?
So wir zwei hier.
>> DENNIS & SALLY: Nee.
>> DENNIS: Ich habe schon auch gerade gedacht:
Okay, wenn ich dann irgendwann
vielleicht mal in einer Folge drin bin,
ist es dann auch Ehetherapie?
Nee, nicht?
>> SALLY: Dann nicht. Nee.
>> DENNIS: Nee, nicht? Nicht. Gut.
>> SALLY: Das wäre komisch.
>> DENNIS: Das wäre komisch. Deswegen.
>> SALLY: Vor allem, wenn du mit dem Murat dann,
das wäre sehr komisch.
>> DENNIS: Das wäre
ja auch okay.
Also, mein Gott...
Also...
>> SALLY: Mein Gott, dann wäre es halt so, nicht?
>> DENNIS: Dann wäre es halt so.
Er ist ja ein attraktiver Mann. Also da kann man nichts sagen.
>> SALLY: Ha ja, sonst hätte ich ihn nicht geheiratet.
>> DENNIS: Eben.
Also hört den Podcast an!
Und ja, es lohnt sich.
>> SALLY: Bis zum nächsten Mal!
Tschüss!
>> DENNIS: Tschau!
>> SAMIRA: Ich habe ihn auch schon angehört.
Lecker Lebkuchen!
[Musik]